come on I feel like I'm the only one
eating here try some of that have some
eggs
I'm so confused these are confusing
times right no no that's not what I
meant no I get it I'm kidding
I know it's crazy I'm wearing shirts now
yeah
how why five years ago we got our asses
beat
except it was worse for me because I
lost twice first Hawk lost and banner
lost
then we all lost no one blames you Bruce
I did
for years I've been treating the Hulk
like he's some kind of disease something
to get rid of
but then I start looking at him as the
Cure
18 months in the gambling I put the
brains and the bra and they gather and
now look at me
Best of Both Worlds
excuse me Mr Hulk yes can we can we get
a photo 100 little person come on step
up your mind
okay thanks
say green
did you get that that's good
you want to grab one with me
I'm Ant-Man
they're Hulk fans wait they don't know
oh nobody died nobody does no he wants
you I don't want to take a picture with
them yeah look he's even saying no he
doesn't come on the kids but I don't
want a picture with him but he's gonna
feel better
no you feel bad take the goddamn phone
thank you very much oh God Bruce
damn Bruce listen to your mom she knows
better about what you were saying
right
the whole time travel do-over
yeah guys it's outside of my area of
expertise
well you pulled this off
I remember a time when that seemed
pretty Impossible Too